not to toot my own horn but I I got in
front of a a movie that was sitting on
the shelf and got it off the shelf I got
it off the shelf I went and I leaked the
trailer on Rogan why was it on the Shelf
it's all the [__] [__] going with the
[__] Putin right everyone was scared
I mean like I shouldn't say this because
I know I mean I know that people even
now people will be like you know but but
everyone was nervous that maybe
perceived negatively I said it's not
about that it's a good [__] movie
it's a funny movie it's a funny it's a
[__] action comedy that has nothing
to do with possible yeah it's not called
Bert Chrysler invades the Ukraine
it's the [__] movie about a story
you've been telling on stage forever but
people were like cats when that when all
that [__] happened down I remember
people going
so are you gonna be able to tell the
machine on stage again and I was like
I'm fine yeah but I don't think my fans
now then no one cares we're all a little
sick of this by the way yeah wrap the
[__] up we've had enough and so and so I
got that off the shelf they wanted to do
the announce I said let me do it I did
the announce
uh this went viral I said let me take
control of getting they gave me the
trailer I said let me take control of
getting that spread out yeah we had uh I
mean I shouldn't say numbers but we had
an a resounding effect with that trailer
within 24 hours same thing with Razzle
Dazzle I did Razzle Dazzle I took
control of all the BTS I took control of
all the marketing I took control of
everything BTS explained what BTS so I
have a film crew that comes with me and
shoots everything and then in that
process we shot the announced the
trailer and we did all the editing we
did all that and then so that's the
business I want to be in is like it's
like just covering my business I don't
need to be the studio I don't need to be
the director I want everyone around me
that's the best but when it comes to
like the little [__] jobs around me
I want I want to be running all those
yeah and that's and I think I think
there's people that are even better than
me that can do even more than that but
that's where I know I'm good at I know
I'm good at selling me to people that
like me right that's it I mean it's like
I do it with stand up I you know I
remember when I got into
when I got when I got the first Netflix
special I was very proud that I got
myself there yeah because you know you
got to get yourself there like you get
yourself there that's I know a lot of
people may
may see that differently when they look
at us but like you you got yourself a
special on Netflix no one got you a
special on Netflix right you did by your
stand up by you're waking up every day
and busting your [__] ass right you
got and that's something to be proud of
yeah yeah and so and and so I remember
getting secret time and I was so proud
of myself I was like I got myself here I
remember I think in the meeting this is
gonna sound horrible you know when you
say something that's just comes out
wrong yes
it was at Netflix yeah and they're
congratulating me on my special
and I I don't know why I said it but I
was like I got myself here
and everyone's like okay I was like no
no no no like no like I wasn't gifted
this like I earned this and it was like
a moment it's good that you no it's a
completely insane moment it's an insane
wildly inappropriate punching me going
thank you well you know what it was I
made mortgage I made a lot of money in
mortgages one month and my and I was
like walking around like I was the [__]
and then my old boss said hey he called
me into the office and I remember I was
so embarrassed he goes hey man act like
you've been here before Oh I am not that
guy God yeah I am not that guy it's my
first time and I'm letting you know it's
a surprise party that you've thrown for
yourself yes all the time all the time